foreign
[Music]
to have both you here Scott thanks for
making the journey I can't believe we
have the shared history of Hoagie Haven
we might provide that context to people
later in iconic landmark of a spot in
Princeton New Jersey and they seem nice
to see you nice finally to uh
to be on that side of the microphone
yeah definitely man and I thought we
would start with just providing a bit of
context for listeners as to how the two
of you connected so Scott how did the
two of you end up meeting
yeah so this was the mid-2000s I was a
reporter at the Wall Street Journal I
still am a reporter of the Wall Street
Journal
at the time
I was covering hedge funds and there was
among the hedge fund Community there was
this book that a lot of hedge fund
managers like to talk about sort of like
this secret book that they were passed
around
that they said it was really great it
was called Fooled by Randomness
so I read that book I thought it was
amazing
but a rumor among these hedge funds
managers was that the the hedge fund
that the author of that book Nasim tleb
he had run a hedge fund
but it had shut down
but nobody really knew the truth of
whether it shut down or not so as a
reporter that intrigued me I think it
was actually Neil Chris a very
well-known Quant hedge fund manager
who put us in touch
I talked to Naseem I got him on the
phone and he said yeah we shut down a
couple years ago but there's a new hedge
fund that's starting up by my you know
former colleague Mark spitznagel maybe
you want to write about that so I had a
story that came out in the summer of
2007 that broke the news that empirica
had shut down at least for the broader
public also broke the news that a new
hedge fund was was launching called
Universe yeah restart everything yeah
similar strategy and also that the
author full by raminus had a new book
coming out the black's called The Black
Swan which explained you know the
transition from
the author was trying to Transit I kept
Megan and I thought no I don't want to
be known as a hedge fund manager yeah
reframe it so I don't want to talk to
you except if you talk about my ideas he
said okay we're going to talk about your
ideas this is why I mean I was I was
trying I said okay on my on my grave
I don't want to be known as a Trader as
a scholar and I remember he was so he's
bringing back a portion of life but it
was at the right time because he
contacted
us right before the explosion
of 2007 and there's a weird connection
right there that I'll mention later to
you right there is a very weird
connection to me and let me ask you
Nasim what prompted you to make the
transition maybe it was a long time in
coming but to decide ultimately to step
out of trading or being active as sort
of a player on the field I know they'll
never stop and I still in my late 30s
early 40s I had time
to really do something else
and I realized the following that when I
had a position and it was I mean I could
be involved in trading but I didn't want
to be the the one
flying the plane see as a passenger or
as a co-pilot Maybe
at a time I said okay Mark is much more
capable uh of running this because he
loves doing it okay and I like the
concepts and the ideas but didn't like
the follow-up positions and because it
was the minute I would be
involved in the trade
it would inhabit me so I felt that it
was there's something in my in my brain
that was slowed down by the fact that I
had to worry about something else other
responsive sense of responsibility so
Mark didn't have that so Mark had he
could compartmentalize isn't that he did
nothing else he and he was initiated I
mean other things of course on the side
of the instruction so he was a benefit
so I I wanted to Transit out so I said
okay I'll take some time off to finish
the Black Swan which I couldn't finish
when I was training which actually I
started before Fool by Randomness
okay okay I saw the Black Swan and then
I said okay I'm going to talk about
Randomness so I got diverted into
football Randomness and then I finished
the Black Swan it was almost a 20-year
thing and I realized that I'd like to be
a scholar who eats well who trades once
in a while with a sense of it was like a
military person who you know has an
honorary discharge to do other things
and and of course leaves a battleship to
those who
live for the battle right okay so that
was what happened and then of course the
rest is history as you know but let me
mention one thing that that probably
your listeners and and viewers don't
know is that of all the people they've
been on his podcast
I bet you I'm the first one you've met
it's quite possible okay so the first
one I met you before I met him
in probably 2001 2002 around that around
that time and the first time we met we
corresponded and said oh this guy is
very interesting ideas about hacking
things
and then we went to a restaurant a thing
on Madison Avenue
and who ate every single egg they had in
the store
yeah I was a good deal larger at the
time and I was yeah all the eggs for
some reason I mean they were worried
about us why how could people do human
beings eat so many eggs so that was my
first
physical encountering corresponding
before and became friends
and there's a interesting scene that we
had that that have in my mind when
Neiman Brothers went bust
basically after our
and then you follow that trade and he
wrote about it actually about the
quality of the trade and the promise of
this trade that were you know
betting on tail events
before the leave-in crisis
okay and on that day that when the day
limit went bust I was on a plane in
communicado I land
and the first thing I got was an SMS
from him because I was meeting you for
dinner and the second thing I got is
news that Lehman went bust
so from the news from Marx leaving went
bust it was the the two messages and
that night I think they ran out of pink
champagne and in the house we were with
Seth Roberts the late Seth Roberts a
very interesting person who also was
studying hacks fascinating guy
yeah really genuine lovely human being
and we did consume vast quantities of
alcohol before Romania we met us funeral
yeah when when he came in and paid for
the bill
surreptitiously and I want to read that
yet tonight
so you'll have the comeback opportunity
with the with the bill this evening and
you're right I mean there are very few
maybe no other guests who've been on the
podcast to predate us meeting in 2001
which is wild and I was probably 30 to
40 pounds heavier in terms of muscle
mass
I was all that Hoagie Haven I was a lot
bigger at that time
I've many questions about Black Swan
also about the trading career but
actually a letter which I'll come back
to I think you'll you'll get the
reference but first I want to ask just
for a backdrop for people who may have
no familiarity with quants with betting
on tail events
and you have this book which covers a
lot of these topics in depth so you have
multiple books but in the case of
betting on tail events
what is a Taliban
broadly speaking and then what are the
different ways one can bet on tail
events and you guys can of course pass
the mic back and forth but but what are
the different styles or approaches to
betting on Tel events the thing I would
say before it launches that the point is
not to bet until events the whole idea
of the Black Swan everything I've been
telling everyone every person I meet is
to bet on disruption on no unforeseen to
not be harmed by silent risk okay that's
the idea the first thing is don't be
harmed by it but of course you know
given that when you study televised they
say these people are ignoring these
risks so they're for their risk in the
system that
people generate and don't see hence you
can you can trade on it and go ahead I
mean this is this is your your your yeah
I mean there's all sorts of different
approaches and I think it's when you
talk about betting
on a table event
I would say that you know what universa
does and empirica before that is I
wouldn't call that a bet
um
I would call that a risk management
strategy and that in a way is what
differentiates them from other hedge
funds and Traders who who do what I
would call you know a betting you know
or taking positions based on a belief
that something's going to happen
what universa does is they are
constantly taking on positions that will
pay off massively in a tail event so
that their clients are constantly
protected and they don't they don't need
to make predictions they never make
predictions it's something that
snagel constantly says is that he is
at forecasting
he's been forecasting you know gigantic
bear market for decades he's been right
a couple times you know but he you know
he will admit okay I you know I can't
predict the timing of it it's going to
happen one of these days and that's what
they provide for their clients is that
constant protection and they do it by
buying far out of the money you put
options it's it's pretty simple not easy
to implement I think which is why you
don't see a lot of hedge funds doing
this because
they do actually do it
and then they go bust yeah they do or
they you know what happened in the scene
it's very stressful because you can go
years without making money in that
strategy
because it's waiting for an extreme
event a very extreme event their
strategy is betting on a 20 decline in
the S P 500 in one month which I think
may have happened once or twice it
happened on Black Monday in 1987 1987.
in one day but they don't actually need
to have that happen to monetize the
strategy they just need to have a very
big decline very rapidly so that
happened in 2008 happened a couple times
in the 2010s
[Music]
in 2020 it happened big time so I
imagine I mean it's for somebody who's
running a fund like this for for you or
Mark that it's it's there's the watching
the numbers
and maybe that form of bleeding chips
stress over time but there's also you
have investors who probably in theory
are very comfortable with the strategy
but who also Panic or have other issues
The Genius of universal is that
they managed to package a product
as insurance that allows the investors
to increase their exposure to the market
so the strategy in it by itself
positive huge return
that's more interesting is that it was
hedging something that went up what was
the stock market do since since then I
mean it went up like 30 percent no no no
in total since say the 2007 it was just
2007 yeah triple yeah went up I say
twofold maybe so you allowed people to
have a larger position larger exposure
to the market than they would otherwise
right and and also there's a cocktail of
other strategies
that definitely didn't fare well because
the entailed diversification away from
stocks so this one allows you to have
stocks so it's very weird because Mark
is always bearish on the market
but he provides people a product that
couples very well was a very long stock
position so that was the secret so given
that it's packaged that way
investors
tolerated some drawdowns too much on the
insurance you see well look at that
you're going to look at you know the
insurance premium exactly versus the
insured for versus I mean hey this is my
differential p l and it's the same thing
when when I started trading options you
have an option hedged by stock
and and and sometimes people only look
at the stock performance and some people
only have the option performance and
tell them no it's Inseparable you see
you got this is called the Delta all
right so that was how they managed but
the other trick that
it has understand that we are one trick
or me intellectually I'm a one-trick
pony I think of nothing else but the
tail risk everything's packaged around
Taylor risk that I do intellectually but
Universal is a one-trick pony
all he does want trade so if you do only
one trade
and for a couple of decades believe me
you know the tricks right you know how
much to put on not too much not too much
you see if you do just one trade and
then people come to University and say
no that's what we do we don't do we do
once you do this for us no it's like
you're making Maseratis right and
someone comes to you say hey why don't
you make trucks we don't do trucks when
we make bicycle we don't do bicycle all
we make is one single item that's it one
single size one single that's right and
that is the main criticism by other the
one-trick pony and that's
what we're proud about what's the
selling point is that we are one trick
ponies and whether in my work
intellectually
was was worried about daily risk or
whether the implant implementation of
universal of their ideas you know Mark's
ideas and one thing just one single
thing so when you do one thing
professionally
it develops a match yeah what makes me
think of I'm going to butcher it but
there's a Bruce Lee quote which says
fear not the man who's practiced 10 000
kicks but the man who's practiced one
kick ten thousand times well there you
go
and but let me come back to something
that you said nothing which was that a
lot of these other shops who maybe
attempted something they thought was
similar went bust what were some of the
Fatal flaws or mistakes that other fund
managers made the first flaw and this I
noticed in in our days that a lot of
clients that had initially when it
started empirical
were diverted into other funds who were
actually mitigating
the strategy by instead of say you can't
buy puts on the S P 500 you buy puts
that are cheaper in some other commodity
you see and and hope that they will
correlate so it was there was a
dependence on correlation so I know
someone
who actually went bust
he said called overriding the strategy
by
inputs on the S P 500 and selling puts
on the German index
to collect more cash out of the trade so
that way you say oh have more staying
power and his investors were proud till
guess what happened
the German Market went on the U.S market
the thing exploded and they're out of
business on an insurance okay so a lot
of our competitors try to mitigate the
strategy we were absolutely first that's
the other thing is
that you noticed was the players in
Reverse if you see if you met Mark you'd
understand it there's no question that's
what we're going to do we're not going
to mitigate no correlation nothing just
all we do is artichokes
Etc that's it we don't cook anything
else we don't no we want administ we
don't Administration
so that was that was how how and in a
way totally the long road not the hack
within the hacks of Trades the long road
is the best yeah so in a way I started
liking your idea of hacking and and
until I discovered over time that
basically all the things I've enjoyed
doing were the things I reverse hacked
so now it takes a long road like right
now last week at the 17 hours of cycling
so that's the long road that's not a
short road whereas when we met I was
looking for shortcuts the university had
no shortcuts yeah
and he takes no shortcuts so I've been
known you now for 15 years
I know I met you 15 16 years and I think
that shortcuts and it was very good that
he wrote that book for one reason
to put some story and narrative around
the idea of precaution and Taylor risk
for society in general and also because
of fact tracking
that document because a lot of these
stories and legends of this has happened
this didn't happen it was a perfect fair
fight because fact tracking reflecting
audited
results and stuff like that was
fact-tracked so sort of fact checking
the importance of tail hedging
for society so and that to me is great
greater than that details you know just
like having having finally a document
someone who bothered to look at the
details and and went through
irrigorous many hours of interviews
documents and double checking the facts
versus anecdote so what what compelled
you to write this book
of all the things that you could write
on why did you choose
to write this one
the birth of the idea of the book was in
early 2020
and we all remember what was happening
in early 2020.
the world seemed to be unraveling
you know we had covid we had
you know protest in the streets we had
extreme political
uncertainty
in this country
lots of things going on
so
the first thing that happened was
in you know
March April of 2020 it came out that
Universe had posted a three-month return
of more than four thousand percent
on their positions which was quite
eye-catching and got a lot of news I you
know reached out to Mark and was like
holy crap what you know how do you guys
do that
so that happened and then I came across
a paper that Nasim had co-written in
January of 2020
about covid and he it was a you know
glaring warning
to the world that this this virus was
very deadly and people needed to take
extreme precautions against what was
coming you know by social distancing
other things advice to politicians that
they needed to be very aggressive about
this
and it it kind of occurred to me you
know I'd known Naseem and mark for a
long time and I thought these two guys
we're in a period of extreme duress
where lots of people are just kind of
looking really bad they're collapsing
they're losing money
they're making really bad decisions
about covid
everybody is confused these two guys
seem to be coming out of this period of
really you know insane insane period
looking very smart
so I thought what is it about their
world view that allows them to go into a
period that makes a lot of people look
dumb
look very smart you know there's got to
be there's something about that you know
that
can map from what universa does to what
Nasim does and it's it's this view of
the world of you know black swans
extreme events of being prepared for
them
and and know what class of events
you should be prepared again so in other
words for years
and pandemics for me was something I was
working on since 2007. they even
discussed it from the Black Swan that
dependent what you have to worry about
is a pandemic for financial meltdown
because of connectivity
we're no longer like in the 1800s where
you know you could have a crisis here
and not there everything's so connected
in the financial world and the same
thing in the physical world
you see the the the plague the Great
Plague took something like 300 some
years to go from Constantinople
to the northern England 300 some years
today is the weekend for the whole thing
for the the president through the entire
planet flying on Lufthansa and
justinians play could not come to the
Americas there were no Air France or no
ships at the time and and now visibly it
can't so understand that we are in a
different environment just like
culturally things can spread you have
the Google effect the same thing
should apply to pandemics so this is why
we were working on yanira and I and
other people on on and particularly a
fellow who is probably one of the
smartest people I've ever met who's a
head of civil service in Singapore at a
time and then retired later and we were
all obsessed with a great pandemic that
would come and we thought it was going
to be Ebola
so I mean you have to worry about
pandemics and
later on I wrote a financial I wrote a
paper and I'll finish that I wrote a a
scientific paper scholarly paper on
pandemics
that I didn't really finish
and when a pandemic struck we put it in
nature of physics
to and when counter nature physics is a
very prestigious I guess a scholarly
publication and it silenced a lot of the
epidemiologists who were like nitpicking
similar to economists like nitpicking
when when you have the these what I call
Extreme properties and at the time in
early 2020 you had a lot of
epidemiologists even the who saying we
don't understand the nature of this
pathogen we need to wait and figure it
out you know the advice was
let's kind of like the what's the the
movie about climate change don't look up
don't look up where the the president is
saying let's sit tight and assess that's
what the message was we were getting
from our health authorities in early
2020 it was sit tight and assess and
that's a recipe for disaster Nasim and
his group are saying take action now if
you wait around to sit tight and assess
you're screwed exactly Hispanic panic
panic early if you must panic panic now
if I can finance and anything you get
out now when it was easy for example to
limit the flights out of omuan or it was
it didn't have to do a lock balance you
could do lockouts I mean other methods
used by the Ottomans by the Ottomans
yeah to install the ultimate and the
austrians had you know the the world was
separate
but they had a lot of traffic and it
went through what they call quarantine
spots so you would go into a sort of
hospital that has quarantine and there's
seven days one way nine days the other
day and they would Implement that the
minute they smell
anything right illness and they had
rules if you come from India as more
days they had they had these the ottoman
had these rules and and it's not didn't
come from the ottoman this long
experience dealing with pandemics and
how you stem and by stopping them at the
border these things were called
lazaritos and towns that did not have
lazaritos Venice of closer Maritime
power they had lazaritos they did very
well
but the Marseille France
was decimated because they didn't have
lazaritos
the lessons we need to learn repeatedly
we have to learn from history how people
handle that they cut it in the egg
that's it yeah
and it's easier to track people at the
border and you don't need to have
quarantine you can just test at the
border we didn't test the United States
at a border until a year and one month
into the pandemic
I don't understand you have lockdowns
but you don't have lockouts I mean just
let's start the borders just test people
at the border that would probably reduce
the fellow from Singapore was testing at
the border he said the way to control it
is by knowing especially testing people
without
they've been aware of it and they
started the first thing where they
detect temperature before the
establisher things secretly at Singapore
so it was I guess they had a warm-up
with SARS so they had the thermic
exactly he's the one who started it and
they were doing it secretly before they
became public so people wouldn't take
antiparetic drugs before landing the
whole idea is that you have to find
fixes and they're not complicated and
one analogy I'm going to give this is
the banker system is that the banking
system
Banks
Mastery profitable Enterprises they make
money off if you're in the float the
money you have that there the check you
them cash all right or stuff like that
they make tons of money
and guess what they blow up
on a risk that Brigham a tiny amount of
money hmm you see it's selling that
option that explodes every 10 years by
saying oh no we're the different
environments will never happen
so sitting on Dynamite so that tiny tiny
tiny tail option is what caused the
banking system
they lost more money than ever made in
history Bank in 1982
Money Center banks that is and did the
same 2007.
okay and the business is usually
profitable except for that tail event so
I'm saying that if you just remove that
Banks would do well it's the same thing
in society if you figure out how to
remove that tail risk
sometimes no it's complicated well let
me ask I'll Stand in for the audience
and also for myself and not to throw my
audience into the bus but why don't
the banks what are the incentives or the
circumstances that prevent them from
taking taking a certain percentage of
their assets and allocating it to
something like a universa so that they
are less at risk in that way they just
don't have to do that they could just
avoid some trade but let me explain to
you the Dynamics of the bonus system
and this is this led to my book skin in
the game later on if you have skin in
the game you're going to worry about
blow up because it's your money
if you don't have school in the game
your CEO of a company or you're a fund
manager any any kind of financial
venture
what is your incentive
is to print good numbers
because you don't pay for the downside
so you print good numbers you take you
you collect money on the profits annual
bonus annual bonus so this I call the
generalized Bob Reuben trade generalized
room and trained he made
100 million dollars at Citibank or city
core or city or something
over 10 years about 10 years he
collected 100 million compensation
the bank was insolvent in 2008 near
insolvent it was for the taxpayer and it
was the last minute
all you have to do is you know write an
apology letter we didn't see these
events this was a Black Swan named after
a book by a very very stubborn man okay
so something like that so that's all you
have to do is say I'm sorry right you
keep your bonus yeah
so this you can generalize it's the same
thing supply chain with a supply chain a
lot of firms concentrated everything on
one supplier instead of being
Diversified
wasn't that little right okay better
bottom line
but when I call pseudo efficiency
because they're short that option and it
so happened that if their supplier is in
Wuhan guess what you got a problem all
right problems that problem was not
doesn't show any numbers it shows after
it happens it's the Dark Side of
optimization exactly what I call pseudo
optimization like if you drive a Ferrari
500 kilometers per hour
you're not going to get there faster
than if you ride a bicycle
because all the time you're never going
to get there
Naseem I have a question for you about a
letter and then I have a question for
you about personalities Scott
temperament may be another way to put it
so the is it true that you wrote a
resignation letter
your first day at a trading job and put
it in your desk drawer I read this on
the internet I don't know if it's true
you can't believe everything you read
but it was from the guardian so I
thought it might be credible no so this
is one thing is actually as I said I
recommend people do that ah
I did that but it was I wrote that but
not the only day I started but I
recommended that people write the record
because you feel relief when you do it
because
then you can continue on your job
without feeling
like someone's controlling you you've
got the gun loaded the whole idea of
plan behind you thought of that problem
so you write the resignation letter
and you
don't date it right yeah
I'm very fascinated by your
ways of thinking the way that you've
embraced different philosophies and you
emailed me an aphorism in 2010 and you
can correct me if I get any of the
wording wrong but it stuck with me
so this is in 2010 here's the aphorism
of the quote robustness is when you care
more about the few who like your work
than the multitude who hates it and then
parentheses artists fragility is when
you care more about the few who hate
your work than the multitude
who loves it and then quotation marks
politicians have you always had that
type of
robustness or resilience against
criticism is that something that is
inborn maybe because I was never really
someone who took
you know established the ideas at face
value so you necessarily have
you know violate some Norms so thinking
norms
and often people protect those Norms by
you know attacking a reputation
and I realized that while riding full by
Randomness says hey you're saying that
what I'm doing is random or using the
wrong models it don't work so they
attack your reputation so I realized
quickly that was time that my reputation
was going to be under some kind of Fire
and and I decided that no my reputation
is how a few important people or people
who know something about the subject
and it's not like I don't care about
reputation I only care about reputation
in some circles
and it was people
I can talk to
to try to explain what it's about and
has worked out so but if you're like if
you have to go defend your reputation
and you're doing the right thing
it's too much energy wasted and it's not
gonna help haters are gonna hate um
I think there's this resembles another
aphorism inspired by Charlie mongers one
of Charlie mongers is that you want to
be the most ethical person
when people think that you're corrupt or
you're the most corrupt person
or a few things that you're ethical
make your choice
and use it as guideline
it's the same thing so except that you
know there's something in between
there's some people
I care about and I want them you know to
not lose respect for me of course you
start with your mother if you have your
children or whatever your family members
but there are also there's a lot of
people on the planet and I care about
notification but in these circles not
with the general public so it allows you
to take much much more aggressive
positions which I've done over a long
life
and Mark for example has a lot of
enemies
and they're going to pick on something
and they don't care so you've done the
right things
and and how do you know you're doing the
right thing if people you respect
approve
of Your Action
not if the general public does
so then segues to my question for you
Scott which is in the in the process of
doing all these interviews
and interacting with these various
players on the field and these sort of
practitioners these investors and so on
have you have you identified any
patterns that you think whether nature
or nurture that seemed to recur
in people who are
good at what you describe in the book I
would say I mean across
all three books that I've written which
are
generally focused on
Wall Street trading hedge fund managers
I've met a lot of hedge fund managers
over the years none like this guy I have
to say we'll probably come back to that
but I'll tell you I don't want to be
identified as a fund manager yeah that's
true it's an identity thing I would say
that's probably why you're not like them
many are very focused on making a lot of
money that's a very common trait I mean
mark
you know he he talked to me about how
you know he grew up in the 80s
he
he identified with the
you know
Reagan Era it was a time you know Wall
Street greed is good he told me he's
like did I have a little greed to me
yeah I did it was the 80s he grew up in
a family that was
kind of you know his father was a
minister in a church he was sort of a
hippie didn't believe in pursuit of
wealth Mark to the exact opposite view
of that and that was constantly
something driving him was the desire to
make money
[Music]
a lot of other hedge fund managers I've
met over the years just they have that
drive and it's something that many
people look at these guys and think you
know
you're worth a billion dollars you're
worth two billion dollars and yet you're
a maniac you go into work every day
and just go you know crazy you drive all
your employees crazy because you want to
be richer than the next guy I don't
think Mark has that you know quite that
sort of
insane level
of greed as some do I've met Ken Griffin
the founder of Citadel a disciple of Ed
Thorpe who we talked about we might talk
about later Cliff asness who is a
Stark enemy of friends initially
initially a friend yeah and I I have to
say Cliff is it as a nice guy when you
when you meet him not a nice guy but is
this I'm not friends who are not those
guys he's also got a dark side
also so many extremely focused on being
wealthy very smart they're all extremely
smart I think that's one of
impersonalities that's I think one of
the things that helps has helped drive
my books is these are interesting people
yeah you know a lot of them are
mathematicians scientists they come out
of
University with a different
expertise and making money but then they
applied that on Wall Street to
making money so it's a combination of
you know a lot of them they have to be
leaders
they
are extremely driven
it's it baffles me because I'm not like
that you know I have a degree in English
and I think that's actually why
sympathize with naseem's writing so much
is
I came out of a tradition that you know
I you know love the works of Dostoevsky
and existentialism and you know one of
my favorite books is the irrational man
and I came in to Wall Street and started
reading about how there's this
belief that people are irrational and
the markets are rational and
they are predictable because of this and
I thought that is just crazy you know to
me I look at financial markets and I see
black swans I I see fear and greed that
to me is what drives markets not
rational Behavior rational expectations
[Music]
so what are some of the things that make
Nasim different
or unique
in in those you've interacted with I
have some of my own questions and and
thoughts on this but I want I would love
to hear yours yeah well I mean he he
mentioned his contrarian nature it's not
a company in nature it's independent so
yeah
I mean people say I'm contrarian I'm
and with a conspiracy theorists on many
other things I'm against them on many
other things some are just contrarian
because they have a father problem
so to me contrarian is an expertise
rather than an attribute so but the
other thing is I thought it's not going
to be about me it should be about the
idea the precautionment well she's a lot
more interested in literature and
philosophy and and not financial markets
that's just this thing that just drives
him he doesn't look at the stock market
page you know every day like some people
do he's you had to figure out talk
people Envy yourself so
you know if you're
in a hedge fund business and and you
have 500 million dollars in a bank and
someone else has 600 million dollars
it's gonna be envious with that person I
was always envious that people had more
erudition
than me okay so more erudite and and you
realize that that's what makes me sick
is I don't want to so if you feel it's
not you know being envious is not good
but at the same time if you figure out
who
it's not I don't believe in this I say
oh people having enough there's someone
here from East Hampton the fellow who
wrote catch 22. it's a lot of
interesting folks out there yeah yeah he
met a financier at the time for hedge
funds and the financier said what is it
that
about you because it was an author a
very successful one what is it that
distinguishes you from me you know look
he told them
I know the meaning of enough
so in other words you know your upper
bound and effectively
I don't play that game I say there's a
meaning
literally and I say envious of people
who are erudite like if someone knows
Latin very well I'm envious someone
knows Sanskrit I'm envious all right so
that's and I discovered that early on so
I made money on Wall Street because I
wanted to make money on Wall Street but
I didn't think it was worth the effort
and luckily it was a combinations
Universal so I had so much leverage it
was marked on other stuff so that's the
spillover on me was more than
satisfactory so I have knock on wood a
lot more than I wish the part of the
reason I'm asking we're talking about
the ideas but the the person who's
acting as the vessel or Communicator of
these ideas the developer of these ideas
is integrally related to I think
the sort of totality that I want to
explore so a part of what interests me
about your story and your thinking is
how various inputs have impacted your
thinking around not just markets but
other things
and
so for instance like the stoics and the
cynically younger and so on or other
philosophical inputs did those
come early and then Aid you you think in
your career when you're active
in the markets or did those come later
and you sort of had it always had a deep
interest but were able to explore them
no it's actually I started liking the
stoics and all those people I've talked
about I like them much earlier in my
life but I went overboard
giving for every idea I've had I did the
exact opposite of what one should do is
like if you had an idea say oh I have
this idea right let's go look because I
don't consider myself so different from
others and then particularly when you
look at history you know so many
surviving works so
I went back and figured out all the
scholars of these Scholars who had
similar ideas or who preceded the ideas
so and who started thinking like that so
I went into the empirics the empirics
the the Eastern Mediterranean Greco
levantine Greco-Roman mostly used in
Greek language thinkers
and and then of course and to others
about this fundamental skepticism
because I noticed a lot of people are
skeptical particularly conspiracy
theories they're skeptical of
small things
but not about big ones all right and and
so they get they get taken for a ride
it's find me a conspiracy theorist or
find me someone who's naturally skeptic
of all things
and I'll show you a turkey
you see so I wanted to find people who
were fundamentally skeptic being
skeptically skeptic about important
things not about small things because
what would be an example of a big thing
that they would be skeptical of I wrote
a paper it was never ended up in a book
on the stock market and religion all
right it's called the bishop
and The Economist
and and I said that those who are
skeptical about
the existence of God and now this is
skeptical about religious matters
typically tend to be complete
suckers
when it comes to stocks they believe in
a stock market or believe in some kind
of pseudoscientific theory
on whatever it is okay so they believe
in but they don't believe in religion
and the reverse all right and people who
are religious typically they're harder
and there's some research on that
there's a guy called me
I think who did something
studies about the skepticism people go
to religion about Affairs scriptures
where it matters and I wrote about it I
think in the Black Swan so skepticism
where it matters and I noticed that a
lot of these big Skeptics
were not skeptical of God and things
anyway we can't do anything about they
were skeptical of
the Charleston the skeptical of things
of someone trying to take advantage of
you that's where exercise your
skepticism among the great Skeptics
there is a bishop UAE he was probably
one of the second most erudite person of
his time second most second verse is
the guy is phenomenal he could
Translate into Arabic it was a
Roman you know authors Latin authors and
vice versa wow
there are a lot of the spear Bale Pierre
Bale
has you know a lot of Works he's one of
those Skeptics Hume was one of those
Skeptics but these people preceded him
humans known because he wrote in the
language of the country that had a lot
of ships and a lot of trade you know
across the world but a lot of these
ideas came from a groups of people
in France or among Protestants in France
and what's called the amphibious
and of course it originates of course in
the Levant and of course you have the
great Al gazelle this is the Islamic
Theologian Iranian origin
who definitely was was showing you how
all these arguments
are weak you know
it could dismantle arguments okay by
showing you to be skeptical about the
human arguments about God
he was skeptical about the existence
about the text but that was these people
say okay transcendis next okay be
skeptical about things that really
matter
and there was actually a skeptical
School of Medicine practicing medicine
so what I went back through history
every time I've had an idea I would go
back and see in history who preceded me
and sure enough I haven't done enough
because every year or so I got a letter
from someone hey how come you missed so
and so okay and and sure sure now I go
back to the inserto and I add that
person and this is why it has survived
the five books the incerto
but we're not here to talk about these
five books with this book
well we're going to talk about whatever
comes up but I do want to hop over
to you Scott and
maybe discuss something that you had
shared with me as a possible bullet in
the prep stages for this conversation
which is related to poly crisis and you
know the new age of Crisis what does
this refer to
it's the subtitle of my book
most people have focused on the first
part of the subtitle is how Wall Street
Traders make billions second part is in
the new age of crisis
and
I feel like that hasn't gotten that much
attention but part of you know what what
I'm trying to argue is that
we are seeing a magnification of extreme
events
accelerating and overlapping
there's a economist Adam twos whose
coined a phrase called the poly crisis
which he says these
these crises that are happening on a
global scale are interacting in ways
that the the whole becomes greater and
worse
than the sum of the parts
so you've got pandemics you've got
economic instability Financial crises
climate change which is a big focus of
mine in my daily job at the journal
which I think is is sort of the the big
one in terms of the ever magnification
of
of crises that we're seeing we're seeing
it in news every day
and
what I wanted to do in the in the book
is
look at
several of these crises and think about
how
we should be approaching them in a sort
of a risk mitigation
a standpoint using ideas from people
like Nasim
I think that the central idea was you
know as I was talking about the germ or
the idea of the book was
can you take
ideas that were created on Wall Street
for risk mitigation and borrow those and
apply those to other forms of risk
management
and what Nasim and Mark do is they think
about the extreme events and how to
protect against them
co-wrote a paper about this exact issue
called the precautionary principle my
next question from the same yeah it
delineates specific categories of risk
that you should take the precautionary
principle and apply it to
he has some specific ideas and he can
talk about it way better than I can
but you know these are things that can
be
Global that represents systemic risk to
humanity
things that can be exponential
exponential things to have these
properties
that you need to take extreme precaution
and and not take that risk basically
don't don't play Russian roulette with
these these risks
and that's kind of how the book was
structured was
first looking at the the growth of the
strategy with Mark and seem
and then moving on to these other things
that the world is facing and
seeing if we could think about ways to
protect against these risks something
like climate change
you don't really want to mess with that
you know it's a it's a bit too late we
still have but there's still lots of
things that we can do
that's I think the book in a nutshell
I was going to mention earlier when you
asked me about the birth of the idea of
the book
when I first suggested it to Naseem and
Mark and the scene said no way I'm not I
have no interest in doing that
with you
it took a while and then you're like I
have these black and white photos you
might want to take a look at it
it was warmed down I think it was more
mark
put the screws on no no let me tell you
what happened I I actually don't know I
know that eventually the promise from
him to not be portrayed to mention that
I don't self-identify as a
Finance person okay and once he made
that promise okay said okay now we can
talk because Finance represents a
significant part of my life yeah but
I've never been a theme with machine
ever since I've known him the identity
piece yeah that he's he's
and I thought I agreed because it's true
it's you know he he's not been a traitor
for a long long time yeah and it's
obvious what you know where his
interests are and I have to ask so what
would it mean or feel like for you to be
broadly identified as a finance person
but to think of yourself more as a
scholar I wrote about it and and Fooled
by Randomness okay
one of the persons on the planet will
impress me the most one of those
and I realized that George Soros
missed his career he wanted to be a
philosopher and thinker okay he ended up
making money and spending too much time
in it and real drunk articles and and
books or until one book yeah it was not
what he wanted out of life okay he's a
middle European
intellectual who would have liked to be
remembered as someone for
well ideas
and he had of course Carl popper who he
claims was his Professor but it was
beyond
so I wrote about it for my Runners I
said here's this fellow who was saying
okay but he also does to distinguish
himself from other financiers is also
orbital has intellectual aims I said I
don't want to be there I want to be
someone who produces
intellectual work and who happens to
have had contact with reality thanks to
trading and thanks to Mark guys I'm
still have some contact with reality but
but but I was not
I'm not cut for that and I don't want to
be in it so when I was writing food by
random cells in 2019
that I realized I was not I don't want
to be like Soros because unlike Buffett
and the other people source
had an identity crisis he wants to be
known as a philosopher okay he said life
took control of him he told me he wanted
to write a book
I used to cover him and
I was leaving the journal at the time to
write my second book and he was like I
really always wanted to write a book and
I never got around to it
so there you go with you know the Oracle
of Omaha yeah he wants to be thought of
as an intellectual too but what I mean
he's just not in the same but but the
the sage of Omaha has something that I
didn't put in a precautionary principle
but that's probably very inspiring if
you understood the asymmetry
if you say no a thousand times he says
no if he doubt and that's the precaution
principle so could you give people the
precautionary principle one-on-one just
to back up okay let me ask you you're
the first flying
to go to Mexico okay you go to JFK
mm-hmm
and they tell you they have uncertainty
about the skills of the pilot but we
think he's good but there's uncertainty
what do you do I do not fly you're not
gonna get on that flight I'm not going
to get on that life is too important for
me you can take a train you'll take you
walk maybe you ride the bicycle you know
take a few months but you're not going
to get on that plane right okay you
change your plans and say okay there are
other plans or other countries too and
other planes though
that's Warren Buffett with his
Investments but that's my precaution
principle the idea that there's a
symmetry is that and there's one
uncertainty about certain things is not
good so the climate for example if you
have uncertainty about the climate stop
these models all right just don't
pollute you get or or try to use
something else try to mitigate so that's
the first part of it and people get it
right away when I give them a story or
plane or I take water as if this is less
water on the table
there's no evidence that it's poisonous
would you drink it
I mean the wording word evidence but it
spook me there is no evidence but when
you tell them hey you know you should
worry about GMOs this is there's no
evidence they're harmful if you have
there's no evidence that they're not
harmful right so the asymmetry where you
put the burden of uh of the asymmetry on
that's a precautionary principle but
then what we did is we noticed a lot of
people in fact it was a counter
precaution principle because a lot of
people were invoking it for nothing to
say we're going to have a non-naire
precaution principle by delineating
the areas
where you should exercise such
precaution systematically as a planet or
as a
communal group and what are they number
one
you need fat tails now what does fat
tail mean let me explain to you
let's say you go to planet Mars okay
Elon would help you get there yes
connection yeah
and you have no news from Earth
[Music]
and then on the way back you hear that a
billion people died
okay
which one is more likely to be the cause
Ebola
or
car accidents ebola ebola no but on a
given day you hear Joe Smith died today
what's more like the Ebola or a car
accident car accident car accident there
you go that's flat tails fat tails you
had to identify
you do things backwards if you hear the
big thing
where'd it come from so then you had to
get these okay so they have different
Dynamics because they scale differently
so in the Black Swan I show the
difference with the following metaphor
they are environments where you may have
a large deviation it's not going to be
consequential because it can't be very
big so if I take a thousand people
and put them on a scale
and add to that sample
the largest human being can find on the
planet how much of the total will he or
she represent
saves 30 basis point nothing yeah and
then if you go from a thousand to ten
thousand
they'll lose completely so you can have
a tail event
that's not going to be consequential
extremistan is different extremistan if
you gather a thousand people and add to
that sample
the wealthiest person on the planet
how much of the total will he or she
represent
yeah
I mean they'll be on average on the
planet Earth right that'd be in total
maybe they have two or three million in
total and then you have hundred and some
billion right next to it so so this is
where you have to focus on environment
that produces fat tails and this is what
Market did Universal the Versa is named
after the universal mechanism that
generates fat tails okay that was that
was the name of the car so everything
we're in it basically intellectually
everything all the details so we had to
identify what produces that
in the financial markets
and why it's getting thicker fat deals
means that you have the greatest
contribution comes from smallest number
of events
so concentration like for example you
have a lot of people all the walls come
from one person well it so happened that
under fat tails the models that we use
for risk management on Wall Street RBS
this is why I have a lot of enemies this
is why I have to protect myself against
reputational damage all right so because
all the economists say to me all their
models are based on on that so what is
fat tail practically everything in the
socio-economy
life is fatal
what is not fat deal number of calories
we're going to eat tonight how many
calories can we have in one day tonight
I mean we can only go for the gold I'd
say I'd say we could each down a few
thousand calories a piece two thousand
two thousand say I go three thousand for
me all right yeah I can play with fat
and stuff three thousand that's nothing
how many calories do I consume a year
yeah it's not a single day it's gonna
make a difference can you lose all your
money in a single day yes there you go
so you have two environment and they're
separable so this is why
the universal approach it makes things
separable
right the fact that you can identify
what is fat tail you identify where
models don't work you can identify where
you have to understand and we have to
use more refined tools to figure out
stuff and then also in fatness of tails
number one pandemics number two Wars
close close second
wasn't pandemics okay and so you can use
that to prioritize application of the
precautionary principle or Bingo and let
me tell you how for example
if
cancer is thin Tails nuclear then tail
you can do if you could diversify it
it's entails if you can have a thousand
nuclear reactors all right if you can
ensure it rather than one
it is syntel if you can ensure it
Cynthia if you can ensure it
non-insurable fat tails so a lot of
things that are
believed to be very risky but they're
not like nuclear for me I mean not for
my one of my co-authors but I'll settle
it with him with a beer or
[Music]
and also a major character in the book
yeah he's very environmentally focused
person he's a leader in climate these
days and yeah he he told me that's one
thing that he disputed
the precautionary principal paper was
missing which was written with him first
drinking English in an English and an
English pub in somewhere in northern
England where the portions are like
smaller than what they give you for
espresso in Italy you know there is so
like you sip them so so we had to have
like twins like with you and the eggs
all right so to go back to the insurable
so we don't have to worry about it a
very simple example I gave that when
Ebola started or later on when when
kovitz started people were using the
arguments yeah you know three thousand
Americans die every year drowning their
swimming pool that was something by the
guy called Dr Phil
should we shut down pools at a time less
than a thousand Americans had died of
kovid
and then I followed this presented the
following argument I said if
I die drowning in a swimming pool
the odds of my neighbor drowning in her
or his swimming pool has not changed if
I die if kovid the odds of my neighbor
died of kovit has increased so he had
that transmission that makes it flat
tail you see that that mechanism of
transmission so so this is why you
cannot compare as basically the press in
the beginning these so-called
established press was against our ideas
because it was racist against China they
could not distinguish between risks of
car accidents and heart attacks
and risks of things spreading this is
why for example I am in favor of
vaccines the risk is thin tailed and I'm
against Ramos because they spread in the
environment let me ask you a question so
I better understand so with the
precautionary principle with the example
that you gave of the water there's no
evidence to suggest this water is
poisonous
in my mind I was wondering if somebody
could use a similar argument against a
new vaccine let me tell you what the
problem is we're not with the vaccine
there are two things number one
if someone takes a vaccine and then you
have partial population doesn't have the
vaccine it's not affected but there's
something more Central here you're
comparing two risks we have covet versus
a vaccine right so you have to compare
and we know a lot more about genetic
stuff in an individual than we know
about how genes spread in a population
[Music]
and That vaccine story basically the
beginning why don't you exercise the
precaution principle I say I have to
worry about a pandemic a lot more yeah
in comparison to comparison to that plus
very quickly after about a billion
people had jobs I was initially
skeptical about a vaccine in the sense
that let's wait and see the story is
are there other ways because I was
really I'm really worried about covet
and people don't understand that the
argument
they use exposed kovitz is much more
dangerous than you think
and the vaccine is what made it
tolerable
so when they had a billion traps I
showed the following thing
that everything is genetic
the number of mutations
to take place to cause a problem okay
they have a variance and if they have a
variance it's as follows you would see
already in a billion people because it's
so much scrutiny you would see
the tail risk to give you an example
Hiroshima okay they say on average took
10 years to or eight years whatever to
get cancer
no we saw it in
three months or months you see if you
focus on the tail
same as Guru Guru takes a 10 years on
average the median to get Kuru from
exposure but you have what is Guru I
don't know Kuru is bad cow disease
things for which we have data of
exposure and then only onset of disease
so I looked at the vaccines with all
these conspiracy theorists and
everything and seriousness the focus is
enormous and we can see anything but it
follows that class of risks where
you have you know you have to have
mistakes going to take a place in a
genetic or DNA this is where after a
billion Jabs I said okay I'm gonna go
for it okay and visibly it's the risk is
much smaller the risk may exist that's
much smaller the risk of covid
and plus there's a lot of numbers about
covet people who aren't aware of
number one something that people don't
think about immediately is that kovid
raised
the risk of death the your multiple of
deaths
across you know beyond the age of 30
because we don't have
much of an effect for younger people or
we don't think so
the force of mortality of the program
like all cause mortality no it went up
from covid across the board
in the same way so in other words
whether say for example you're supposed
to cover your ten percent chance of
mortality in one point one percent ten
percent increase in our cold mortality
it's the same for young people hmm so
past the age of 30 it's about the same
number
so it could be 20 more depending on your
exposure
so saying it's an old people problem
they were dying as a multiple of their
mortality rate so I took the social
security numbers just to you know and
say okay it's not my numbers Social
Security number
look at it if you're uh
female 30 year old you have one in 700
chance of dying male 1 400 chance of
dying that goes up by 10 percent okay it
was coveted if you're 80 years old you
have one and whatever it goes up at 10
or something I mean the 10 depends on
the exposure period but it was almost
flat across the population so I said
okay do you want to increase your
children's chess
or young people's chance of death by X
percent
plus the effect it has on
years lost and and life expectations
much more dramatic for a 40 year old
than it is for a nine-year-old
so this is how I looked at it and of
course by then we had eight billion
traps yeah so we had the answer how do
you think about say GMOs this is
something I actually don't know much
about but in terms of the precautionary
principle and risk assessment how do you
think of I mean a vaccine is to counter
a disease GMO is just like manipulation
that people said oh we've always
manipulated animals all right but that's
not true
it's sort of like there's a difference
between flying and walking okay in the
risk you can encounter you see the GMO
the way it was a gene would spread
through the environment it's like an
uncontrolled uncontrolled spread is fat
tailed whereas
selective reading is very slow yeah as
Rupert Reed said he cited I don't know
who said that as your horse is a blind
make sure you write it slowly and so
there are two classes like mediocrestan
extremistan I mean you understand like
calories or extremely sand stock market
[Music]
selective reading versus the GMOs I mean
you're jumping so many steps with GMOs
so it's a different class of risk right
because of the I mean the risk of
uncontrolled spread exactly and then you
have a blight that spreads you know like
of it did the whole planet and we're
much more connected than before so I
said you can do it and plus they have
never done a proper risk study on GMOs I
mean environment not not one they're
saying there's no evidence they're
harmful look people are eating it first
of all you can't you have no I mean I'm
a scientist I like to see around the
minds control studies I like to see
things like to see something a little
more formal than claims and and then you
just don't realize what happened no
matter what you say about Monsanto I
think would be a
an underestimation of their evil
attribute because they really erect
science because they had groups of
people who would go and intimidate
scientists and people on a salary
scientists are frustrated with their job
losing a postdoc position
they would contact your boss
they'll contact practically everyone
they did that to me but visibly there's
like water on the duck's back
why'd they do it hundreds of letters to
the university because of your
commentary and GMOs because of the
principal paper paper and then somehow I
use the r word
in the past in French it says like
you're a slow thinking person
I got it I got it then they would have
took me some letters from mothers of
children with special needs yeah who
don't like that a professor at NYU would
use such a language that's insulting to
myself but the point is when they showed
me the letters
they have different names but it was
like written almost on the same
letterhead exactly and the language was
the same language so I realized there
was a smear campaign plus there's a lot
of other things they did
petitions all kind of thing an online
harassment but with me it didn't work
with others but the people they select
for these things are usually dumb but
think about it who would engage with
smear campaigning the brightest person
you know probably not okay so you can
play with them so monsato did is to
cover up for whatever they're doing
if your intimidation
they disrupted science and they made
people believe that hey no evidence I'm
doing science this person is of higher
later or whatever is called the ludite
yeah you'd have been against the fire
anti-science is a anti-science because
science anti-science and usually they
never used by scientists
and they had a few scientists who knew
nothing about the risk and probability
so that was but anyway we had fun
fighting it was a long fight but then
what happened they were brought by Bayer
and the Bears a little more civilized
than Monsanto and all that disappeared
so if we if we zoom out and look at the
precautionary principle
how could that be applied on a
policy or regulatory level like if
someone's listening to this and they
agree with the premise
and they said this makes a lot of sense
how could we implement this on a
larger scale level such that we are less
vulnerable to say the risks that yes
possible risks well actually in Europe
the precautionary principle is widely
adapted among
International agencies and Regulatory
Agencies
I think that the advance that Nasim and
his co-writers made on the principle is
is that it can be kind of fuzzy
so it can be seem to be subjective about
how you are applying the principle I
think what they did was create a
category grouping which can be used to
designate things and you know you could
have panels that would look at it using
these categories
but I think if it were adapted more
widely among regulatory agencies in the
United States just as a principle as a
way to think about certain kinds of
risks
then it could be
more generally applied and and useful
like I said in Europe they do use it
GMOs are
not widely adapted in Europe
and primarily because of the
precautionary principle and they have
lobbyists in Europe
they do have lots I know because they
all attacked me I mean for so I see them
online all the time okay coming from
Europe Italy for example Italy of all
places you know the best place to damage
it big time is a reputationally if you
had GMOs and Italian food in Italy had
no tourism but they still have people
there trying to sell particularly that
when you sell GMOs
you also can use more Roundup
I'm sure there's a secondary effect on a
soil and it's the same people who are
producing both right yeah nice so one
could be an excuse to sell the other but
in another to me one of one of the
really interesting aspects of of the
precautionary principle is the notion of
uncertainty you know when you look at
climate change the uncertainty of models
has been used as a casual
by the deniers and buy the fossil fuel
industry for decades that there is a
level of uncertainty in these
predictions we don't really know how bad
it's going to get we need to sit tight
and assess the risks that we're facing
and
what they showed is that uncertainty is
a reason for taking precaution because
if you are uncertain about the potential
future destruction of or massive
degradation of the biosphere because of
polluting it with carbon dioxide and
methane and other greenhouse gases maybe
you should stop doing that or realize
that you're actually taking a risk you
don't know what the risk is so
uncertainty is actually a reason for
precaution rather than just throwing
caution to the wind and just saying well
we don't know so you know what the hell
ironically what happened to me the first
time I formulated the argument
um it's actually in the Black Swan
second edition and I was with David
Cameron on stage and I said we have
uncertainty about these models
so avoid these models and just don't
pollute the paper I'll later rewrote
with my friend yanir and others by
saying the more uncertainty there isn't
a model the more you have to be if it's
like the more uncertainty you have about
the skills of the pilot the more
cautious you should be exactly you
should take another plane so what
happened the next day
20 newspaper articles in the UK
calling Black Swan author the climate
denier okay trying to convince Cameron
so it probably has a conscious industry
of modelers who would be out of business
if you follow these principles so it's
not like we got heat a lot more heat
from the left than from the right
but why were they calling you a denier
if you said they used me verbatim or
that follow the whole argument and they
say well he said that and I basically
named them by names and I went after
everyone and there's 20 journalists I
wrote to every Journal explaining to
them what I said
and I say they signed me out of context
and I wrote a chapter in
in the skin of the game about how was
the debate an honorable debate is was
where you represent the person's opinion
like what call Papa always very
facefully represent the person's
position and then attack it whereas they
were taking
select the cherry picking creating a
straw man argument exactly and that's
for you would say give me a letter
written by an honest man I'll get him
hell huh
so so the problem that you have with the
climate that a lot of people have
an interest
and complicating the story in fact you
just say okay let's forget about fossil
fuel let's pollute with other things
just like I say if the drug is dangerous
I use half of that
sorry the dangerous dangerous
non-linearity we put that in a
precautionary principle the
non-linearity the convexity that's the
theme of anti-fragile the complexity so
you're constantly dosing the atmosphere
with carbon dioxide
you're going to end up with a very bad
outcome eventually exactly Let me Give
an example to go back to before when
we're talking about when I used
GMO versus selective breathing tell me
why speed and fragility
an example I use in the
anti-fragile if I Bank a car against a
wall at one mile per hour
a hundred times okay
it's not going to be the risk of your
banking at once at 100 miles per hour
right okay so this is where if you have
acceleration of harm
like if I jump 10 feet I'm harm more
than twice
than if I jump five feet
so we showed we're in the presence of
acceleration what to do and that part of
the paper was never understood because
people don't understand convexity
although anti-fragile is currently my
most successful book it's read more in
than it was in 2013 second year of
vacation
so as same with Black Swan I know the
Black Swan is read more and now than it
was a year after publication but
in spite of all of these arguments being
presented okay
people can grasp our paper and I
discovered why
something I I figured out only recently
when I talk to young people at 23-24
they know exactly what I'm talking about
the parents are the problem
so what is convexity just to refresh
okay so and again we're going to talk
about Universal or anything embedded in
a universal story but that the convexity
is if you make more if the market goes
down 10 you make a million dollars if it
goes down 20 you make 10 million dollars
you have to convex it
and this is what everything is based on
well in general is like yeah yeah that
were called convex and concave probably
the best illustration is how we fared in
and I explain it then the Black Swan
right before it happened I looked at the
risk of Fannie Mae by deserter who you
know left anime and distributed the risk
reports okay
we looked at risk of anime and notice
that if the markets say an interest rate
or
risk or mortgage premium or something
like that is increased by 100 basis
points they lost X
286 points 20 times x
three honest basis points I said they're
sitting on a barrel dynamite in the
Black Swan 2007
five months later
okay this style is going on and
eventually they lost the book 600
billion dollars losses okay why they
said oh they reacted to me by saying oh
we monitor our risk we have 15 phds okay
15 or 15 trillion phds it's not going to
help you with this so this is convex it
on the losses and we're doing the
reverse
on the profit side and there have been
some a lot of people get upset the way
Mark presents the numbers that he writes
to his investors you know you filed with
the SEC with all the numbers are
available they tell them listen we made
four thousand percent on your maximum
loss okay whereas if you invest in the s
p you can lose 100 of what you have so
the return that you have on that maximum
possible potential loss in other words
when you go to bed in the evening all
you could lose is that much and how much
these options were explosive under
maximum loss all right yeah so that was
the ASAP asymmetry is four thousand some
percent but that's not the first time
that happened nobody noticed before the
crisis of 1987 there was a plaza Accord
where a bunch of people got together
secretly on a Sunday and then and made
an announcement we're gonna
support the currencies against the
dollars the dollar is too expensive you
had a huge move
I was at work we had a tiny risk
so an explosion of my p l
okay they brought detectives or
inspectors to figure out why the p l is
so large for that so little risk because
you had maximum risk all you could lose
is say x thousand dollars and that
exploded that's how it works
they couldn't believe it right so
I decided okay I'm going to make a list
yeah when you say exploded this is in a
in a bad way or a good way good good way
the piano yes the p l was too large for
the risk they say we're supposed to only
say computers couldn't handle the
numbers yeah no so for them high risk
High reward how are you getting
low risk High reward no no you made too
much money you got to be taking risk
you're hiding something from it that's
what I mean and the computers would take
something like
10 hours at a time to compute the p l
at the end of the p l you see so every
time they said go redo it and stuff like
that and I was frustrated because I
couldn't understand it they couldn't
understand it but this is the same thing
happens
for you know that's the beginning of the
trade that became empirica University
something like I remember when I was
talking to Mark back in 2008 he would
never tell me this now but I was trying
to figure out how they had such
incredible returns and he gave me an
example of a trade that they made and
it was
I forget the timing but it was like a
July 2008 S P 500 put option
betting on a 20 decline in the S P 500
but for two bucks
after the crash
he sold it for 60 bucks
that's the kind of convex exponential
return that you do not get in any other
kind of trading and you just you take
that two dollar option you magnify it
over millions and millions of dollars
you got four thousand percent return
yeah but they're even more dramatic than
two dollars or sixty dollars you always
look at how people have lost money
because when you read
the you know reports and stories they
hide the losses because nobody's going
to write a book on how they lost all
this money it's always invariably the
same there was a story of volume
investors I think they're selling out of
the money options on gold
and they're selling for five cents and
end up have to buy them for
forty dollars and then there's a neither
Hoffer story same story where you're
liquidated and what he blew up I mean he
blew up many times but one time book you
can see the prices it's sold off for
five ten cents
and then they had to buy him back and I
was buying them back up to forty dollars
that's what I noticed was selling
volatility selling out of the money
sales said something rare events
and you don't need a large deviation
just people panic they pay anything
because or sometimes they're forced to
because the Clearing Houses or
counterparties cannot handle the risk
see we're going to close you out sorry
and you close out there's no liquidity
it's like the famous saying sell
everything
and then the clerk
I told you sell everything why are you
not moving Sid
please tell me to whom sir
let me let me ask a question that's been
sort of uh percolating in my mind and it
may not be a good question but I'm
curious you mentioned Soros and I don't
know that much about service I've never
met him but
I use I I want to say service is also
known as the man who broke the bank of
England right or the yeah the British
pounds so one of my questions is in this
increasingly interconnected world where
the equivalent of the black plague
whatever that might be and it could be
in pandemic form or otherwise instead of
taking 300 years is over a weekend in
terms of spread and things are so
interdependent
is is there the Temptation and the risk
of investors catalyzing
more crises or different types of crises
not just
I don't want to say being Spectators but
there's one thing to
to have an investment methodology
that has certain
premises and so on that then results in
a windfall return at a certain point in
time with tail events but I'm wondering
if
I mean it seems like there are hedge
funds I'm not saying this is what you
are there are investors out there and
hedge fund managers who take very active
roles
in
companies let's just say that they want
to take a position and activist
investors and so on it's and I'm
wondering if investors will be able to
do more damage as the world becomes more
interconnected may not be a good
question I'm just curious it's an
excellent question do you want to answer
it I think that it's possible I see the
damage coming from
you know negligence and bad risk taking
that ends up you know creating a
contagion effect just the same thing
that we saw and not among investors but
like in the banking yeah banking or
hedge funds or crypto
um
you know I I think that
financial markets
over the past 20 years and increasingly
with electronic trading are more and
more interconnected than ever and this
is something I got in my second book
about high frequency trading is how
you could see the potential risk of some
giant move in say a derivative contract
or an index something overseas
because
trading machines are correlating all
these assets globally electronically at
hyper speeds microsecond speeds
that you could see
something move very rapidly
into all sorts of asset classes in a way
that is impossible to to stop because
it's so fast that could be triggered by
a Trader or it could be triggered by a
computer just go on bananas yeah we have
noticed very early on in the 90s a
phenomena that International
diversification
was no longer a diversification
why because of that integration
dramatization
a lot of good things hold people out of
poverty but a lot of things happened
with it number one you can't diversify
anymore because if stocks collapse here
as we saw in 87 collapse everywhere for
large large deviation and now for mild
deviation starting in the 1990s
and also I mean the funding disappears
everywhere or the comes everywhere
so this property of globalization
is similar to the one that came with it
is that like we're gonna have shortages
and then gluts now in a phase of in
between shortage and glut
but shortages can be very deep
where containers go
up 10 times I mean container shipping
container and you're gonna have
a lot of
the reverse happening because I've never
seen shortages without
gluts I've seen glass without shortages
but never shortages but they're very
deep we didn't have that before we all
depend on
thank you
the whole the world's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger but it's like a large
movie theater
was the same door
you see it's the size of the door that
matters when you want to get out not the
size of a theater
so with the supply chain is narrow it
has got an error now probably it will
expand and Branch out and we'll have a
better network but people would not
understand that this is this is why
people like to sell tail events because
it costs money
to
diversify
your sources of you know whatever
and and your supply and it also costs
money to hedge daily risk or you think
it costs money you know you have the
illusion and sure enough you're to
realize that
if a hash is expensive you know think of
absence of hatch how much more expensive
it is so what's your perspective on the
capacity of
investors
to catalyze
greater risk not necessarily the
systemic
risk taking although this is certainly a
factor of say the banking sector or fill
in the blank but
very well-funded
investors who are looking for
Black Swan or Black Swan like
opportunities
their ability to create a
self-fulfilling prophecy in a sense okay
as I say predictions ourselves and I'm
probably not wording that as well as I
should but as I say predictions are
self-fulfilling and also self-counseling
say early on the self-fulfilling people
get on the bandwagon
and then and they're sure enough you
know that's how sort of the glut takes
place after the shortage but one thing
you know this white one should realize
was the structure of the world in which
we live
that
although history is not indicator
for many things because we live in times
of different connectivity and stuff like
that the rules
of what can go wrong are very simple
you see it's like pandemics okay the the
Ottomans and the austrians figured it
out or lazaritos okay simple right then
venetians were experts at it okay the
rules are very simple they're not that
many of them then when we talk about
precaution principle a lot of people
have the illusion that it multiplies
into zillions of regulations no
one comment I'd like to make about The
Regulators like European regulators
they're great at being Regulators now
there's a regulator for pleasure
and if you put 200 000 people in
Brussels you know of course they have
great french fries and beef Tallow
fat whatever but at the same time what
comes with it is these people are going
to regulate you out of existence on
things that are trivial they like to do
the trivial because it's easier to sell
so they regulate
vacuum cleaners all right that what how
much energy should be or the speed of
of your windshield wiper on a farm
tractor if this has windshields that
kind of things but they can't control
the borders
and they didn't think of covet
of all the people we spoke to because a
lot of people try to talk to me about
risk thinking that you know
that you should talk to someone like me
about risk okay
and usually I get upset because Hey
where's the next black one I'm not
getting it it's a Singaporean government
because they were they didn't fear very
well it was covered as much as they did
before I think maybe because my friend
was gone or something but but they were
they know they said okay what can go
wrong and let's reverse engineer our
heads you see sort of like the reverse
of what you think
and build things in a way to withstand
that kind of saw
other other examples outside of
Singapore I'm very interested in
Singapore and I guess who is it Lee Kuan
Yew and the entire story of Singapore is
pretty wild
any models or leadership outside of
Singapore not necessarily related to
covet although it could be that you
think does a good job of applying
precautionary principle or working
backwards in the way you described all
traditional societies you know
traditional societies are traditional
communities like Italy where there's
this GMOs and
and also people online may say oh this
is anti-scientific they know it's you
know it's not science is not about that
for example so it depends on which
domain there's some domain some people
are good at some domain on others like
Russia is very good at some classes of
risk but not visibly at others it
depends on countries like Italy got
paranoid about
but nuclear
and uh
there's one attribute of our environment
that we should realize
is
the non-trivial effects of propaganda on
the mind of people
particularly once well organized
the KGB was not very good
a spine
we discovered
but was very good at this information
so everybody panicked about
the nuclear
because they didn't want Reagan to put
ballistic missiles in Germany
and and they infiltrated put in no
something about it when he was in
determinist he infiltrated all these
green movements
by directing the greens against the
nuclear for example
so
I truly think that that
were suffering a lot from this this
information up today
when people worry about some risks not
others another example of that is
Germany with Fukushima yeah that freaked
out over something that actually didn't
kill people shut down their entire
nuclear program and
in its place opened up a bunch of
coal-fired power plants
which is you know obviously much more
direct risk to humanity than
nuclear power plants that don't kill
people the radiation in Chernobyl I mean
we I knew that when I was running the
Black Swan I didn't talk about it
because I know it was dicey was lower
than that in Utah
but it's not the point it's Chernobyl is
too big if you make small reactors let
them blow up it's not going to go beyond
so what happened is because of convexity
um you see one reactor
is vastly more dangerous than 10 small
ones and the tense models are not like
this blow up at the same time
so that's one
I I don't one reacted how what's the
what's the factor you know what's the
multiplier but but they are
nonlinearities but definitely when you
have a lot of small ones you can blow up
at different times
one time about our previous conversation
when you say the banking sector the
banking sector is very safe for one
reason it's a utility
with high-paid Bankers living around
here
you see have big Soho lofts 10 million
dollar Circle laughs basically the
utility because they don't let it go
under
it's
when it's not the one you're gonna worry
about
it's the saving it again they have to
worry about the effect of saving it like
that we saved it in 2008 was what the
government debt and we exploded
and then again in 2020 there was so much
commercial paper and so many things
again all these things aimed at saving
the financial system
bankwise have spillover effects but
they're going to save the magnets back
system because you cannot operate
without it plus another thing has
happened is that banks used to take a
lot of risk
since 2008 the risk has migrated from
Banks to hedge funds
now it's less concentrated but it still
can be concentrated
in what way can that be concentrated in
other words he has a friend who has a
big fund that's larger than a lot of
banks yeah you see you mean Citadel I'm
not mentioning names so you have a lot
of big hedge funds you know and they
have but I guess they can be Diversified
hedge funds have skin in the game in
other words the owner of the hedge fund
has money in it unlike a bank where you
just have
the upside not the downside of course
long-term Capital Management is the
counter example
of the game okay so so those are very
systemic no no it is people the the skin
of the game is a disincentive of course
but it also scanning the game is a
filter
you see so where are the people from is
anybody from Lockdown Capital Management
still around last I heard John
Meriwether was
10 years ago trying to start a hedge
fund but there we go so if you can't
recover the skin in the game has fallen
effect with you the reason you don't see
crazy drive too many crazy drivers
is because they're dead because you have
flick risk on others but you experience
the same risk so you tend to exit the
pool
so it seems then maybe maybe I'm
misunderstanding but that the migration
of risk-taking to the hedge funds
assuming that the
you know the the GPS or the people
running the fund have sufficient skin in
the game would seem to be a
net positive yeah hedge funds are okay
but we have had the risky part the ones
the most fragile the private equity
and of course by far
people who need funding because I don't
know if you realize but we had since we
had our three bottles of champagne Pink
Champagne
four months whatever a lot of pink
champagne to celebrate lemons departure
from this town since then yeah we put
them straight that close to zero
so when I was you know
students and everything for me an
investment was something
that generates cash flow to build
something that generates cash flow so
you value cash flow and no residual
value at the end okay and then so you
can have you can tolerate negative cash
flow if you're going to get some later
on or if
so it's like us if you discover gold
later on there's a so the business model
was cash flow based with a short-term or
long-term cash flow
the world has changed all right
in the funding world what is the game
now
is who you're going to sell your company
to I see you're talking about startups
in this case exactly startups or a lot
of Investments you buy an apartment you
buy a house you buy a building by
something or you invest in some crazy
idea
and someone was contacting me about
about llm model models you know PT but
say oh we have this startup I'm
investing in the startup
and and look at the rationale and then
he said yeah I'd be able to sell it in
within two years I said listen this is a
trap okay so people so companies say
even Twitter was operating
on a following modus we go to the market
okay as a cash machine
rate cash
so basically everything was came from it
has Ponzi characteristics someone else
will buy our company or we're packaging
a company to sell it to someone else you
know that started before the the great
financial crisis but it was very
moderate
of course it took place during the crazy
period of the internet bubble and then
died
so we had had episodes of that effect
but now it's ingrained and and people
have now for 15 years of low interest
rates you have people in their 40s I've
never seen interest rates and they don't
know how to behave they know how to
invest so I think the most fragile part
today is not the banks of course as we
said and it's not hedge fund because
it's sort of like mature adults
typically
it is those startups and advantages
actually played quite a nasty game
because they cashed out all of them are
rich on companies never made a penny
you see I know there's a lot of it thick
how many billionaires you have and
silicon from Silicon Valley right
whoever made a penny
this valuation maybe yeah yeah there's
there's a lot to that game I will say
also I think they're gonna be
tremendous
just
fatalities in the next probably
three quarters in the startup world
because there's been a lot of
contraction of funding which I think is
ultimately probably a good thing but a
lot of these companies are raised it's a
necessary thing yeah no that's well
right I mean it's it's calling of the
herd so I think we're going to see a lot
of it think about it this will finally
we've got Waiters
obviously because we have shortest
waiters okay we we finally was that way
I mean you go to restaurants and you
know they have one waiter for the whole
room and he said we get more waiters
we've got more people who you know will
help you mow the grass and stuff I mean
we've got a lot of supply
former former startup Founders serving
you your Negroni we'll see we'll see how
it shakes out I'm curious to see
Naseem and are there any
ideas Concepts you would like to discuss
is there anything that we've missed Ed
Thorpe you could always talk about it
complexity is a center of things so I
started writing on convexity or studying
complexity
you know after between the time
we had the you know the eggs and the
champagne eggs no no the eggs the eggs
was 2002 2001. and since then I had a
some 80 scientific papers so and so so
my enemies they don't have to handle it
because they kept saying it's not
science so anyway so I think the the
central thing for me is convexity and it
led me into papers and oncology medicine
because again
unconscious new stuff ducks with new
stuff but their language that the
language they used did not accommodate
this notion of convexity ten times one
the nonlinearity they sort of suspected
it was not formalized so just published
something in oncology
we did a lot of stuff in epidemiology
on Tails so convection tales and
convexity is is the most important for
example people don't realize that
convexity means your life volatility
where you're convex and people missed
the point that was already mentioned in
a paper I wrote before kovid
on citing sources for long ventilators
that if you give someone a dose of 100
the person may die
but it gives that person 80 120 percent
they have much higher survival rate
why because I like volatility like we
like to get things our system likes to
get volatility like heart rate
variability like when I wrote
anti-fragile I was writing between 2009
and 2012. nobody
ability
you see as they thought you need to
study heart rate it's a predictor of
this
but so so it's the same thing for a lot
of things where you have that's a
convexity effect so that's sort of what
I'm focusing on now is these convex
responses convex the stuff applied to
fields
where
you know they need to be applied like
medicine I'm saying it was nutrition
the nutrition figured out early on in
terms of fasting well it's a convexity
thing instead of having a dose
throughout the day you have it then it's
a different response but there is a
limit you see you'd rather have your
calories the concentration limit whether
you have your calories
you know once the day is okay once a
week not so sure you see so there's an
Optimum thing it's the same thing can be
generalized to others this is what I'm
working on and it's taken me a while
and all that comes from optional the
option Trading does it make sense for
people to become familiar even if they
never engage with options in some basic
education in options trading or would
you say skip that and study skip that
because they're going to sell options
they used to say nine tenths of option
players will be will come in will be
sellers
I think it's 99 out of 100
it's so appealing but someone's going to
give them the story
you sell option you have steady income
there's nothing people like more than
study income and the reason Mark is in
business because he's the only person I
know
who doesn't care about
having studied the psychological prop up
for having studying because everybody
else has to study income they will
debase the trade to have a steady income
and sure enough you get studying the
income by selling the tails
and that is generalized to give you an
idea companies that have steady income
are short an option somewhere
you see so it's not trading option that
will help you is looking at optionality
in business
and in places who will short that
optionality that you can have two funds
they all have now same return
one font can be
have a lot of short options
and One Fund can be robust
you won't be able from the outside and
security analysts have no idea weapons
of mass destruction that's what Warren
Buffett called him so Ordinary People
should stay away from these derivative
contracts
and it's one of the things that I
had to deal with this book was it's with
my editor and
you know in people who I've who've
interviewed me since then is everybody
wants to know how to do the universal
trade you know Mom and Pop how how do
you how does Mom and Pop protect
themselves against these things because
in the book I worn these downturns are
very bad for your portfolio this these
are things that kill you you know if you
go down 40 50 percent
this is something that Mark talks a lot
about you lose 50 percent to get back to
where you were before it happened you
have to make a hundred percent so these
are the things that you really want to
protect yourself against and my editor
was like well you know you want to know
for his own because he was getting
scared
how does ordinary person do this how do
they protect themselves against these
big events my answer is an ordering
person should focus on her or his
business
dentists would focus on Dentistry not
trading gold yeah I mean my experience
you see people whose business is not the
finance
and they think that they've got to make
money out of their checking account
so what happened that they have so much
scrutiny about their own business
say they're on a bakery they know the
suppliers this guy pays these guys they
know all the risks and then they blindly
put their money into something they've
they have no idea what's going on okay
so so this is where the sucker you know
what I'm saying is dumb independent some
people are skeptical in one area but
don't transfer to the stock market it's
the same thing so so there's something
about the stock market particularly with
the the weakness of religion that makes
people believe
and stories of returns but not believe
in theological arguments that we've had
for 2000 years so it's the same thing
this is that sucker that and tell people
listen what do you do oh I have a bakery
focus on baking and then and use your
money to preserve
that's not your business
so this is where you tell the pop and
Mom you don't tell them how to do
Universal trade you tell them
they can't do it that's the problem as
well I mean I I get the you know after
being in Silicon Valley for 17 years and
having some pretty good luck with
startups I get the question like how can
I invest in
early stage Stardust I'm like don't yeah
do not under any circumstances do that
it's like unless you're living in the
middle of the switch box and you're
dedicating your time to that do not do
it unless you're a Trader don't trade
yeah unless you're a baker don't bake
unless your Dynamite maker okay don't
make dynamite and stuff like that but
it's Elementary
this has got the new book chaos Kings
how Wall Street Traders make billions in
the new age of crisis
is available where all fine books can be
found
can you find you online Scott
pattersonbooks.com on Twitter at
pattersonscott and let's see where would
you like people to engage with you if
they engage with you or with your books
understanding that you
have begun work on these these various
I suppose parts of your multi-part essay
at different points and time is there a
place where you would suggest people
engage with your work first I suppose it
depends on their orientation I think
full body Randomness is the one that
people like the most the blacks want
what they Slide the most and
anti-fragile is the one they misuse the
most misuse yeah because they say oh
yeah the virus you get stronger what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger I
know but what kills you doesn't make you
stronger I mean they're not getting it
right like they're the first thing to be
fragile to be anti-fragile is first
you'll have to eliminate fragilities you
see that that's the first rule eliminate
you tell the risk you don't open it up
so I don't know but I'll say is full by
Randomness is a good start
[Music]
or if your lawyers come in the game
I have no idea because
I'm not thinking in terms of my past
books I'm thinking about the book I'm
writing now yeah what are you working on
now
two things as a technical insert or
second volume which is all scientific
papers around these points and I'm
working now on a book that is pretty
much like structured like
like an ancient Roman latinous Latin
language threatis
okay with questions and and stuff like
that and it's liberating to be able to
write
without having
The Narrative
Point like and in it I cover all these
points question what is convexity what
is it says so and I've decided to do all
of that in one book
and it's going to be called principia
for example why the risk of an
individual you know getting this is
does it translate into Collective risk
in the same way right the swimming pool
versus stuff like that and also why for
you you can generalize a lot of it has
to do with scalability
people have the idea that we should have
a virtuous individuals to have a virtual
Society
typically if you force no there's a lot
of greedy individuals can
build a virtual Society that's the Adam
Smith's argument or I said One Mile
Branch so the idea of scalability for
example is the most misunderstood thing
like a town is not a small village I
started the topic in antifragile but how
things scale differently
so a town is not the same Village
but it's not a large Village a country
is not the same as a municipality
and why for example you could be
libertarian at the national level and
autocratic at the municipal level you
see our Communists in the kibbutz but
libertarian state level you could have a
lot of these radiations so things are
more complicated
among these things I debunk in it and
then finally one one idea that also the
explosive structured in it on
the main difference between BS and
non-bs
[Music]
because a lot of scientific papers have
BS and a lot of casual things don't have
BS so I'm exploring all of these in a
volume
I may call it Suma or principia with
narrative title yeah
or Suma or Pinkie Pie in kirtorum or
something
so what characterizes non-bs I have to
ask I have rigidity of meaning
rigidity of meaning I learned that from
Arbitrage reading I learned a lot of
things from training and arbitrusting
the law of one price like if you combine
things you should they should have the
same price here Singapore or downtown
Uptown combination that you should have
no Arbitrage I can't really buy an ace
of the Arbitrage I used to buy I started
doing arbitrages like buy an option with
this this converted to a crossing and
end up with something cheaper than some
other one I would short and then just
get it so it should not have a lower
prices a relative meaning
whatever words you use always refers to
the same thing
that's what my criteria
in it by the way I cite you in my new
book well hopefully it's a good citation
when you call bigger tiering oh yeah
okay so in other words I have a
so-called retrospective build Theory I
have one section is on scalability and
one section on is on the passage of Time
how we don't get time right and in it I
explain why
for example it is improper
to blame someone retrospectively
for values we have today where we don't
have then yeah you see it's like for
example Aristotle he was you know a male
chauvinist from itself say okay is it
was it
is wrong yeah we know now but
he didn't know you see he didn't know
it's just like saying okay why don't we
blame it for not using a computer okay
this is a computer at a time so you got
to look at these terms it should not
flow back values backwards but
effectively the talmud which I've been
studying for a while it had a lot of
things on it and and tell me what it has
on it that it says so for example to say
Noah was virtuous for his day
someone pointed that to me in a talmud
because I got a lot of Twitter is very
helpful
I like these ancient
text to see how they they would judge
their own you see like if effectively
when in 18th century
there are different values in the 15th
century and how did they judge them and
at the same time people the wise people
know that hey they did not it was not
part of the Customs at the time
how did you decide specifically on the
talmud because because that's not your
upbringing no it's because I like
Aramaic which is closer to my
native language is the levantine dialect
RMA
and and then started having interaction
on Twitter with people who are televised
Scholars
based on the interest in the language no
my interest in language I have interest
in Asian languages more than interesting
ideas but I'm poor with languages
so
it's not taking me anywhere except
exploring text and I'm enjoying you know
the stuff so you could have a collection
of ancient wisdom and then
that is very interesting because
it explain I mean the the the Monumental
work I'm just wondering I guess in
addition to or amongst the different
sacred texts or scriptures that you
could study why that stands out now what
stands out really is more like someone
like Aquinas
because written by one person
whereas the talmud is a
concoction of opinion on opinions right
yeah so
but I like the talent only because I had
the privilege of understanding so many
languages so I'm enjoying it for more
for linguistic stuff just for the fun I
see it's fun to read something and you
understand this is why I'm jealous it is
effectively a buddy of work that's quite
Monumental you know that took
centuries to build a collection of
Scholars talking about Scholars and And
discussing one another over time this is
what I like
I like about acronyms is took a topic
and boom put everything in it all the
questions and answers you can have in it
they question themselves so this is why
I'm much more impressed with Aquinas
as an individual I can never imitate so
that could be as a scholar like one of
those attributed to that talmud you know
or one of small contributors that
Collective piece of work I'm jealous of
your ability to engage with the Semitic
languages
then just be able to access some of the
the text in its original form I'm very
jealous of that now I enjoy that I I
don't do as well with Greek as I should
Asian Greek no better was Modern but
Latin is
is easier there's so many connections
but the grammar is more complicated than
RMA than land well we could go down that
rabbit hole maybe sound save that for
for the next round I know we have food
and boost to get to but Scott is there
anything else you'd like to mention
before we wrap up anything that maybe we
didn't get to or anywhere you'd like to
point people that I didn't mention
or the next book that you'd like to give
a teaser for anything anything at all
that you'd like to mention before a lot
I really appreciate you taking the time
I appreciating
taking the time
I don't know about my next book I mean
I'm right now just
completely immersed in this climate
world and
last year the bite Administration passed
the inflation reduction act which has
nothing to do with inflation but that
thing is sending shock waves through the
climate technology World in ways it's
just it's kind of mind-blowing and
changing the game
for America at least and and its attempt
to catch up with what China has started
10 more than 10 years ago to develop
these Technologies but it's going to
take a while
but in my opinion it's it's pretty
necessary to start doing that I find the
entire space super fascinating and I
know we were talking about the the ideas
in the current books we didn't spend a
lot of
didn't allocate a lot of real estate to
that particular topic but you know I was
thinking about what you were mentioning
about climate change and the some of the
challenges and engaging different
parties and what I've found I live in
Texas right
a lot of people engaged in the
hydrocarbon businesses and so on and
I've spent time with a lot of these
people who are not stupid right there
there's some very smart people but there
are
you study the incentives and you see
certain behaviors you looked at the sort
of incompetent interests and where I
have found productive conversations to
be had is if I avoid certain types of
language so for instance if I don't
mention climate change but I say let's
put aside the question of whether humans
are causing this or not which is very
painful for a lot of people to do but
it's a great way to fight you know but
if I'm like let's put that aside and
just look at extreme weather events
and look at some of the upside potential
with some of these Technologies and like
where they could find incentives like
Financial incentives outside of some of
their current sandboxes I've had pretty
good luck engaging people with that I
don't always have the most compelling
opportunities to immediately present
them necessarily although there are I
mean quite a few out there I've been
working on some stories about
climate technology in Appalachia so I've
had a lot of conversations with
Republican lawmakers in States like West
Virginia about efforts to bring in
renewable energy into the state
and you can have perfectly rational
conversations with them and they love it
and you don't talk about global warming
or you know climate change you talk
about energy yeah and you talk about how
you know why would we not use this new
form of energy that's actually cheaper
than everything else you know wind and
solar
and they get that they're they're like
we're energy people we we understand it
and they're embracing it yeah I think
energy Independence is
sort of the competition with China in
competition well I guess we can say that
for round two but I really appreciate
the time from both you and took a ton of
notes for people listening also we'll
have show notes linking to everything
that we mentioned as usual at tim.blog
podcast so you'll be able to find
references and links to
and certainly everything I have in my
notes and a lot more that came up in
conversation
any last parting words gentlemen you're
not gonna
play with dinner this time I'm paying
okay agreed agreed
the last time he wanted no games I won't
skulk off and surreptitiously pay for
anything
so on that note off to dinner we go and
thank you very much guys and to
everybody listening thanks for tuning in